esta fotografía fue publicada por la
casa blanca justo después de que yo
vaivén terminar el diálogo con vladimir
putin una conversación de más de una
hora el presidente bardem habló con el
presidente vladimir putin para dejar
claro que si rusia proceda invadir
ucrania estados unidos y nuestros
aliados impondrán un coste rápido y
severo a rusia el presidente bites end
ha instado al presidente putin a que en
su lugar se comprometa a la desescalada
y a la diplomacia el presidente putin
respondió una vez más diciendo que no
está satisfecho con las respuestas de
washington a sus demandas de seguridad
especialmente en lo que respecta a las
garantías de que ucrania no entrará en
la otan el intercambio fue el tercero
entre los dos líderes en los últimos dos
meses pero aún no se han producido
avances las tensiones han alcanzado
nuevos límites eeuu dice que una
invasión rusa de ucrania podría ser
inminente estas son las últimas imágenes
publicadas que causan preocupación a
occidente ejercicios militares rusos en
la vecina belarús no muy lejos de la
frontera con ucrania
eeuu y otros países han pedido
ciudadanos que abandonen ucrania
mientras francia continúa con su papel
de mediador en la crisis emanuel macrón
habló con el presidente ruso a primera
hora del sábado
el diálogo genuino no es compatible con
una escalada militar las conversaciones
diplomáticas continuaron el sábado por
la tarde con el presidente ruso hablando
con su homólogo bielorruso alexandr
lukashenko
el presidente francés macrón llamó a su
par ucraniano volodymyr selenski y al
canciller alemán olaf scholz que viajará
a kiev y moscú en las próximas horas